ok
[Musique]
m
la famille ouais ouais
bordel oisifs veux-tu précisant va bien
les amis es
mon piège tout coup là ça fait plaisir
carrément allumé qui m'ont laissé un
guerrier on dit attaquer talent tabouret
et le pose autres mais le micro sur le
tabouret géant fallu aller chercher le
tabouret apprécié été chercher le micro
est si merck pour l'entrée papy tu
méthanier pas là l'année prochaine ça va
ou quoi elle en cours
ouais
face à un public de feignasses ce soir
ou quoi je fais du bruit les frères
allez allez allez
haha ça fait plaisir mais c'est la
famille c'est bien faut toujours dire
c'est la famille comme ça les gens se
disent ah t'as vu mais qui nous quitte
déjà moi je kiffe personne chercher un
suit d'elancourt je suis lent courtois
courtoisie que dalle
le mec a trouvé le monde et l'encours
était une feignasse locaux look où nous
aurons ensuite les élans courtois moi je
suis sur le mec il a vu deux élans
courir et l'a dit ce sera l heure court
après il a tué un des deux élans et l'a
vendu
et quand il a vendu le mec il a été
grapho c'est pas le client il a dit
mercier aux mecs c'est l'huile a dit mme
mercier aux clients et là c'était un
courtois frère après la d'hyères on sera
les lots à lui a pas compris déjà au
boulet ce pas il y aurait une vidéo tu
pourras voir ma blague je te laisserais
réfléchir je te laisse reçu mon facebook
si tu as besoin je te ferai un détail de
la plaque
moi j'ai grandi elle en cours ou
intermarché
mais sur le intermarché sur le toit de
mon père il nous avait fait une baraque
tu aurais vu sa magnifique on aurait dû
une villa mais sur un intermarché
non je déconne on était sur le parking
d'intermarché
c'était agréable il y avait des pompes à
essence quand il faisait chaud l'été on
se mettait de l'essence dessus ça
rafraîchit sait
il n'y avait pas les moyens de faire une
piscine et comme le chauffage était cher
on s'en servait aussi l'hiver c'est un
concept de vie on était à côté de france
miniature et le mettre à l encours qui
s'est dit on va faire la france
miniature
mais si vous croyez c'est un génie juste
le mec qui l'a pas mis elancourt dans la
france miniature et ça toute ma jeunesse
on m'a rendu fou je me suis dit le mec
il habite une ville il a une idée où on
va tout faire emmener dans un pays il a
même pas mis sa petite ville en tout
petit
[Musique]
après j'ai quitté il encourt un jour mon
père m'a dit tu sais fils je fais partir
je veux tu crois pas tu pas où il m'a
dit je pars en jamaïque
je suis dit mais pourquoi je pars pour
la droite fils gros la city papattes a
du culot
tu peux pas partir comme ça encore moins
de dire à ton fils dis moi je sais pas
je vais voir un concert de bob marley
quelque chose alors il est parti
les magnifiques est-ce que tu veux venir
avec moi c'est que oui mais moi je
prends pas de drogue 1 il ya les enfants
dans la salle
pris à des adultes qui répondent oui
on prend pas de troc les enfants c'est
pas bien il y en a il en a pris la via
des adultes quand des enfants dans la
salle pourquoi il ya des enfants qui
répondre à cette question
il marche sur la tête cet public vous
dire à vos enfants ne pas prendre de
drogue
c'est pas bien la drogue mois à cause de
papa quand on est en jamaïque
je suis parti deux semaines survenu je
me rappelle tous que dans lequel elle
revient sur moi un beau voyage
on sait pas non pas moi j'en mets trop
raconté
alors après quand je suis rentré il a
fallu j'habitais à trappes
ah ouais voilà là tu passes tes
l'encours à trappes
mais c'est pas si différent tant les
justes et l'encours village et plein de
belles maisons
tu rajoutes un épicier qui ferme à deux
heures une crêperie qui ferme à deux
heures et un capa qui ferme à 2h plus en
plus quoi mais c'est bien c'est évident
de faire les courses
mais ça coûte cher j'ai même porté pour
le couple mais qui tient le cap ap
je lui ai dit tu fais exprès mais qui
reste ouvert
quatre heures après le front prix ce qui
te permet que moi et ma vie de
feignasses on vient de dépenser toute
note une c'est toi tu m'as dit si vous
voulez j'ai dit bien joué très bien joué
et puis après quand je suis revenu à
trappes le logement c'était bien mais
pour payer le logement et le quai pape
dans le logement
il faut travailler
j'avais la flemme
franchement j'avais pas envie du tout
mais je me suis dit il faut bien
travailler
alors au début je cherchais plutôt du
côté de paris j'allais dans les
entretiens d'embauché parler comme ça
oui bonjour la qualité n'ont pas ces
défauts je suis assez flou long mais bon
principal c'était bon
je suis le seul à être bon ici oui
je te remercie mon pote
à paris j'ai travaillé dans un endroit
avec des gens que j'avais peut
rencontrer et qui
il en faut un c'est comme tout il faut
que tout le monde soit amoureux tout le
monde c'est le principal
mais imaginez un peu le truc quand tu
rentre le soir et explique à tes potes
que ton rh
il sort avec ton pg
que l'autre vendeurs qui travaille avec
toi il est question bat r abbas a jasé
au quartier tout le monde disait m'a
tuer les quais tu sais mais nous on va
peut-être
et puis dans le fond est-ce que c'est
grave mais je me suis rendu compte que
je n'étais pas vraiment gay le jour où
j'ai fait ma première soirée quai âgé
était oui moi aussi j'étais très surpris
je me suis un peu fait avoir
le thème c'était orgie grecque
moi enregisté la bouffe tu vois je me
suis dit on va manger plein de kebab
opus c'est paris peut-être culte et baby
ferme à trois ou quatre heures encore
plus arrangeant 4 ap
c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait de la sauce blanche beaucoup de
sauce blanche faut pas en abuser
attention il ya des gens qui me disent
c'est bon pour la peau vous essayez de
dire ça à ma première petite copine je
me suis pris une grande tarte dans la
gueule et ma [__] dans la pardon excusez
moi alors pardon on m'a dit c'est un
spectacle familial moi j'aime la famille
ils vivent la famille
du coup premier soir on a mis en moi et
me dit on va bien la soirée je m'habille
en grec en dieu grec
je sais pas si quelqu'un déjà vu mes
pectoraux dans la salle
et pourtant
il faudrait que je fasse au moins six ou
sept modes prison avant de prendre un
mec compliqué compliqué alors du coup je
suis arrivée à la soirée
je me suis dit je vais arriver un petit
peu plus tard comme ça il me
remarqueront pas ils m'ont tout de suite
vu déjà je suis arrivé il y avait des
mecs ils étaient déguisés vraiment dieux
et déesses grecques carrément il y avait
un mec il avait fait une couronne sur sa
tête avec des raisins ils étaient
maquillés il avait une mini jupe qui
terminait ici et un stream qui terminait
là ils avaient des talons qui arrivait à
mon genou et le vexer malades et à
l'aise toute la soirée
et là je me suis dit respect j'avais
compris le truc moi j'avais mis un short
pas foule gars
il ya même un moment un mec il est venu
me voir et m'a dit t'es torontois
j'ai dit oui il est parti il est revenu
et m'a dit ce n'est pas pour moi
j'existe et pour quelqu'un en plus
c'était pour qui elle m'a montré un mec
je lui ai dit non non je peux pas
s'arrêter avec plaisir enfin j'en serais
rien en fonte qui paraît que qui ne
trouvent rien à rien il ya des gens
qu'on trouvait ici
à chacun ses délires moi je juge pas
mais je constate
mais ce qui est bien avec les quais
c'est toutes les filiales ont un
meilleur poker est là quand les gays
font des soirées tous les gays y ramène
leur meilleur pote copine à leurs moeurs
pas de leur mère copine est là
la soirée commence à devenir cool parce
qu'elles sont pas gays avec toi tu es le
seul hétéros qui te fait draguer par les
gays les meufs en deviennent jalouse non
mais c'est tout un concept
c'est un truc parisien je pense nous
celle où auront lieu on peut pas
comprendre le train il est trop lointain
40 minutes pour y aller par un train
toutes les heures tu peux pas te rendre
compte de la différence trop compliqué
alors du coup cette soirée or j y
kebab raté j'ai appelé cette soirée
alors au fond de la cuisine en train de
rouler en deux roues les dents de rouler
à vélo dans la cuisine je faisais des
tours de vélo dans la cuisine c'est là
il ya une belle demoiselle il perd
mignonne tu voyais que c'était une fille
un peu chic du mois grosse grosse des
lèvres imparable caraïbes où elle
pouvait faire genre du tomtom avec ses
lèvres un truc 2 tu vois elle est venue
boire et hamdi est beau gosse de
latérite et compris la part d'abb
j'étais tout seul en train de faire du
vélo dans la cuisine du gouët sanji tu
fais quoi
je roule à vélo je lui dis tu veux
monter sur le guidon m dit non
rentrons albert jacquard web mais j'ai
plus patriat je te préviens tu vas être
obligé de payer le berre ça l'a pas
dérangé samedi arnaud le principal c'est
pas le problème c est toi voiture c'est
gentil s'est gentiment j'étais comme un
conte j'attendais mon premier train et
était à 6h30
il était à peine 23h30
ah non ça c'est les plans qui a l'air
heureusement mademoiselle habite à
neuilly la cage d'escalier mon frère est
les boîtes aux lettres
elles étaient toutes au mieux tout au
mur il n'y avait personne dans la cage
d'escalier je n'avais même pas mais qui
dormait dans un duvet ou quoi que ce
soit aucune misère j'ai rien vu car on
est en escalier les marches tout les
mêmes sur les marches tout les mêmes les
mecs ils avaient mis un tapis rouge
tu imagines tu rentres chez toi tu sois
le du travail le soir tu es là tu
arrives dans un tapis rouge dans
l'escalier qui même mec j'ai réussi ma
vie c'est tout réussi bon le père s'est
planté de route
il nous a menés à bon temps au début ça
allait mais la nana mathieu qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
pourtant après du canal de l'ourcq elle
s'est mise en citer toutes les origines
possibles autour du canal de l'ourcq jël
inquiète pas moi je suis trop j'ai la
psychologie de la banlieue j'ai chopé
l'auberge du tiers au tournage et il
frère il faut que je voie ce bâtiment
du coup on se retrouve à nuit sheila
bair et vous devinerez jamais elle avait
quoi dans son appart sa vue vous n'avez
pas deviné qu'est jean et non cette
promenade à kick toi vas-y qui l avait
kouakou qu ali doucement doucement tu
atteins coquin
bien sûr que je vais me glisser dans ce
lit un chat non je suis allergique c'est
moche c'est chiant je comprends pas les
gens qui aiment les chats y en a qui
aiment les chats bon ben ouais ça
m'intéresse même pas vous voyez non
parce que ouais non mais franchement si
j'avais un chat ce serait pour acheter
un chien pour qu'il bouffe le champ bon
c'est un concept c'est un concept on
peut pas juger constater et du coup avec
cette nana non non elle n'avait pas de
chat n'avait rien dit effectivement mais
elle avait une semaine et je me mets
dans un appart
moi je me voisins et fêter des créatures
sont pas le coup de temps en temps mais
c'est tout jamais on est qui s'est dit
je vais faire une cheminée dans mon
appart
c'est nous disent on est heureux d'avoir
le le chauffage collectif qu'est ce tu
veux que j'aille acheter des bus de bois
sérieux enfants c'était un délire
c'était sympathique bon après il était 3
4 heures moi je lui dis franchement je
vais aller me coucher
elle m'a dit mais tu veux pas jouer
sinon franchement là moi je vais me
coucher
je dis ça parce qu'il ya des gosses mais
où chacun
vous avez compris pourquoi j'ai dit si
[Musique]
et
le maroc s'est loupé encourus ni pas
tout
voilà c'est comme ça contre la mort ce
timbre on dit maintenant
mossoul balad
alors vous venez à la table sur de l'âge
alors messieurs de l'âge comme ça vous
croyez que c'est la fête je faisais la
fête derrière avec la wii alors pardon
oui bonsoir à tous
pact été lâchés soit aussi fait plaisir
alors ben ma vie reste le baby pourquoi
tu t'emballes papier match du coup c'est
quoi ton actu voilà je pars voir mon
père en jamaïque la semaine prochaine
oui après
vu que la demoiselle avait l'air d'avoir
pas mal de sous je vais essayer de me
marier rapidement et sinon j'ai un
poteau un vrai frère de la stream qui
fait un spectacle de ouf qui s'appelle
antoine improvise avec lui-même et c'est
tous les samedis et dimanches parce que
moi j'ai pas de promo je fais celle des
autres ouais d'accord c'est ça tu es
bien voilà vous voulez encore plus dire
merci à tous merci matthieu remportent
honte à vous mr bah voilà comme un
tabouret mais voilà c'est la fête mais
oublie assez génial
[Musique]
ça
tant que big n
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]